hello world Shawn grooms here with free
code camp and in this video I will be
giving you three tips on how to learn to
screen mathematics the first tip is to
stay calm
people often hear the word mathematics
and panic and when you panic you stop
listening and if you stop listening you
can't learn the material so if you
simply stay calm then you will be able
to learn the material better you aren't
being graded on the subject so there's
no need to panic
the second is to rewind you can rewind
the videos at any time and when I learn
discrete mathematics I didn't have this
opportunity so in theory you should be
able to learn the material much faster
than I was ever able to so I strongly
encourage rewinding videos finally
explain once you think you understand
the material of the videos you can try
to explain the material out loud either
to yourself or to a friend if no one's
around or you feel weird talking to
yourself then you can try to explain it
to rubber duckie there's a concept in
programming called rubber duck debugging
which is where programmers go through
their code line by line trying to
identify bugs in their code by
explaining it to a rubber duckie so
similarly if you go through the material
of the videos subject by subject you
will soon be able to identify any gaps
in your understanding of the material